Hello, and welcome back.
So in this chapter,
we're going to talk
about how to add
leaderboards to your game.
A lot of what
you're going to see
is actually fairly
similar to the process
for adding achievements
to your game.
So hopefully we'll be able to go
a little faster in this lesson
and get some leaderboards
added pretty quickly.
We're going to follow
the same format
as we did last time,
by adding in a button
to view all of our leaderboards
before we actually go
and create any.
So let's do that by
going into our game
view controller dot nib
file, and-- oh, I'm sorry.
Not our game view controller,
our intro view controller
dot nib file.
And there we can see our button
to view our achievements.
Let's go in and let's
add another button
over on this side.
And we'll call this
one leaderboards.
Fix our auto sizing in the
bottom here, and then over we
go.
All right, wow, perfect.
That is a beautiful button.
And just like with our
achievements, let's hook
it up to dot
[INAUDIBLE] file here,
so we're going to
move over here.
Let's hide this,
get some room here.
Oh my gosh, squeak this over.
Right.
So first thing we want to
do is control drag, up here.
So we have our IB outlet.
Call it view
leaderboards button.
And so we can disable
this as needed.
And let's say, how about
above our achievement stuff,
we're going to add a [INAUDIBLE]
mark, view achievements.
And we can add another
one as view leaderboards.
And we will add an
action here, which
will be leaderboards
button was pressed.
And let's just take this
full screen, here we go.
And now in this
method, basically we're
just going to create a
leaderboards controller,
and set the delegate to
ourselves, and present it.
This should look very
similar to the methods
we have right above.
Now, I'm going to call GPG
leaderboards controller.
Notice by the way, we have
both a leaderboard controller
and a leaderboards
controller with an s.
The leaderboard controller,
this thing here,
is what you would use if
you wanted to bring up
the scores for an individual
leaderboard The leaderboards
controller starts
by showing you all
the possible leaderboards
for this game.
I'm going to start by adding
an A leaderboards controller,
and we'll get to that one
later on in the chapter.
But we'll just say
leads controller
equals GPG leaderboards
controller alloc in it.
We will set our
delegate to self.
And now we can present
view controller,
leads controller animated
yes, completion handler no.
Great, we're getting a warning
that we're setting our delegate
to self, without
declaring that we
are a leaderboards
controller delegate.
So we can do that right here.
Leaderboards controller
delegate, there we go.
And now we get a warning
that we haven't implemented
the required method, the
leaderboard's view controller
didn't finish.
So let's add that.
We'll do it right under here.
There we go, leaderboard's
view controller didn't finish.
And basically we'll just
dismiss view controller
animated yes, completion no.
Perfect.
Oh, wait.
Maybe not so perfect.
I see I made a mistake here,
I declared a delegate to self,
and what I really want
is leaderboards delegate.
Sorry about that.
All right, there we go.
Now that warning's gone away.
All right, let's do
one more thing here.
Let's go down, and
we'll also set ourself
dot view leaderboards
button, dot hidden also
as not signed in.
And, all right.
And gosh, I think that's
all we need to do.
So let's run this.
All right, welcome back.
We're signed in.
Let's view our leaderboard's
bring up our leaderboard's
controller that is totally
empty, because we don't
have any leaderboards
in our game.
Well, that's boring.
So we'll say we're
done, that goes away.
And congratulations, we've
put a blank view controller
on our screen.
So next step, let's
create a few leaderboards.
And we will do that
in the next lesson.
See you soon.